the question is that amendment f8 as in
f4 Freddie be made as many as of that
opinion say aye
of the country now tell us for the eyes
some might pinning and Nigel Evans tell
us for the nose
Wendy Morton and Ian Stewart
for the government in over a hundred
possibly over 200 so that's why the
opposition have done this it's pretty
clear and I think we should just take a
step back on all of this remember when
mrs. May became Prime Minister she
became Prime Minister because David
Cameron having called the referendum and
had it go against him decided to walk
away so mrs. May had one job her one job
was to unite the country behind Briggs
it and here we are two and a half years
later and if the vote is anything like
everyone is predicting tonight she will
have totally failed
she won't even have managed to unite her
own party behind her version of brexit
and that is the extent of the crisis the
country's in of course following on from
the general election which she called in
2017 in the hopes that that would give
her a majority to deliver brexit into
her terms and of course she lost her
majority then so whatever happens
tonight the country is in crisis it does
not know where it's heading on brexit
and crucially the two sides those who
want to do something to mitigate the
offense of brexit and those who want to
go for a hard brexit are both still
rampant and pushing it I mean nobody at
the time of the referendum campaign
talked about welcoming the idea of a
hard brexit leaving with no deal that is
now Boris Johnson than a favorite to
lead the Tory party that is now his
primary objective and he of course
believes that he will benefit from chaos
for mrs. May so there's an awful lot in
play and it's very important because if
you believe anything like the number of
independent experts and government
experts the consequences of leaving
without a deal which as very involved in
all Professor Vernon Brogdon or rightly
reminded you is what's on the statute
books at the moment it's only 73 days
time of leaving without
the economic consequences and the social
consequences
many people believe will be pretty
severe because remember all those
agreements that are proposed a
transition period are a citizen's rights
all of those would go and so we are
heading into uncharted waters now as
mrs. May said she's probably going to
try and come back with another version
of this deal but look at it our
opponents have got their tails up
tonight yeah extraordinary times Adam
thank you very much indeed for
describing them and Vernon Bogdan Orr is
here with me now alongside John Craig
our chief political correspondent is
about Oakshott political journalist and
commentator on the form of Downing
Street director of communications sir
Craig
Oliver lots to discuss as this voting on
that amendment to continues in the House
of Commons and let me start with you
professor Waldron or Adam Bolton put it
there the Prime Minister's totally
failed at the wrong job she had
extraordinary talents I mean there's no
sense at all this is a night that could
lead to the Prime Minister standing down
well perhaps Adam Bolton was a bit
unfair to the Prime Minister's
difficulties the Tory party is riven in
two on the question of brexit that
reflects I think a division in the
country its division almost straight
down the middle and at the moment she's
holding the cabinet together with
extreme brexit ears like Liam Fox and I
could go Andrew Letson with people who
may be argued to be soft Brick City as
Philip Hammond the Chancellor David Galt
Lord Chancellor and a few others and the
compromise they've agreed on is the deal
so that itself is something of an
achievement as it were to have got this
far without breaking up the Tory part in
breaking up her cabinet but here it
maybe she does have a hurdle which she
can't overcome we don't yet know what
the size of the defeat will be I imagine
if it's not too heavy she would try and
bring it back again she has been dogged
and determined she's gone on and on and
often commentated said well this is her
last week in office but she's still
there Boris Johnson isn't still there
David Davis is still there lots of
others aren't still there
she's still there leading the government
so she's had a problem which has
defeated so many Tory Prime Minister's
the last one being David Cameron but
also John Major and Margaret Thatcher of
holding the Tory party together on this
very toxic European issue well thanks
for it just want to focus for a moment
on there the chamber that of Commons
there as you can see yeah and peas have
already voted only voted on and a many
looked at two trees amazed withdraw
agreements at the moment here and those
that have voted returning to the chamber
I'm just wanting you to focus if you can
on the the gentleman in the olive green
suit with his back to us who I think his
Labour's Clyde Lewis perhaps the woman
then stooping down to talk to someone in
a wheelchair who is chulip Sadiq and
this shows just how crucial this vote is
this evening she's the Labour MP who has
postponed a cesarean birth she had
planned a caesarian procedure planned
for today she's postponed it to come and
vote and as you can see you can just see
that the wheels of the the wheelchair
there I think she's already voted in
this one and presumably will stay there
for the the next boat which will be on
Theresa Mays exit deal and that should
happen within the next half an hour or
so judging on the number of MPs who
filed back after voting on this
amendment John Craig our chief political
correspondent is with me ladies just
focus on that jives part of it is quite
extraordinary just explain the
procedures there are meant to be pairing
procedures that if you have to have
something like this you can then more or
less cancel out your vote with someone
from the opposition I don't know if you
I don't have you ever seen that great
play this house which is all about the
late 70s and they rather comical
accounts of some of the dramatic ways
the then Labour government's trying to
win votes sick MPs being brought in on
trips and so what has happened today in
fact yesterday yesterday in the House of
Commons
Harriet Harman and one or two other
Labour MPs said to the speaker that she
should be allowed a proxy vote this is
Tulip Sadiq she's nine months pregnant
she had already announced that she was
going to delay her caesarean but a lot
of her
Labour MP so this is daft she should be
allowed to vote by proxy and the speaker
got quite cross about it yesterday one
of many occasions you've got quite an
cross in the last few weeks and said
that we've discussed this in various
committees this should be allowed anyway
and of course the government has say
well she could be paired now I don't
know whether any MPs are paired tonight
I suspect possibly not you remember
there was a round you months ago over
the Lib Dem MP Swinson who was on
maternity leave that was this one but
anyway so she's decided to come in this
there's about they're bound to try and
sort this out because I think I'm right
in saying there's another Labour MP
who's pregnant at the moment as well
assume they're both there but this just
shows what a crucial vote well I mean it
does show what a crucial vote it is but
it's my work shot I mean it's not as if
the numbers are likely to be close this
normally happens it's gonna be on a
knife I think to many people this just
shows how stuck in some ridiculous Dark
Ages Parliament actually is I mean this
is a ludicrous thing let's not feel too
sorry for little baby because I'm sure
there'll be some fun conversations when
it's when it's old enough to understand
about how it was delayed so that it
could not to go through the mob it's a
thing you've got to remember is what's
coming next is there going to be a
no-confidence vote yes and that then
becomes absolutely crucial have a nice
evening one no but it's no but I think
the hope from both sides actually is to
get it done tomorrow well let's just
talk let's just get up to that point
then you're expecting we're all
expecting to resume to lose tonight and
Labour have said Jeremy Corbyn said on
Sunday it would am very soon they will
table a vote of no confidence in the
government that could lead to a general
the signals coming out of number 10
tonight are they expect to lose big and
I think even allowing for expectation
management they are thinking this is
going to be a seismic defeat the thing
to watch for is of what does Theresa May
do immediately after that does she do
what David Cameron did when he lost in
the Syria vote immediately walk to the
dispatch box and say I get it or does
she say I'm coming back for another go I
think a lot of that she's probably
already decided what she's going to do
and whether or not she's actually got
something else to say that allows things
to move on and
be reshaped well we know number 10 did
say today that she will come to the
despatch-box
after the big vote regardless of the
outcome but of course it may well the
the next few days may be taken out of
her hands a call if mr. Corben moves a
vote of no-confidence that debate will
have if you move if he puts it down
tonight
it'll happen tomorrow if he doesn't do
it till tomorrow to be Thursday Tory MPs
there are three love isn't that unite
the Tory party I mean you get a partisan
attack from the other side and there you
are gonna split always there's no
expectation that a vote of confidence
would succeed in Labour's terms and it
seems that you know the rationale for
doing it therefore seems very odd but it
allows them then to move on to their
their next phase of their their prong of
attack which may be to push for a second
referendum
I just wanted to reflect a little on the
Prime Minister's speech and I thought
that she made a bit of a mistake
actually ramping up in that very kind of
historical way about what a big moment
this was if she's going to lose was that
really wise indeed I'm just gonna
concentrate on that shot in the House of
Commons so this the aftermath of the
votes on the on an Irish backstop
amendment that's as you can see yeah
what gives well certainly in the House
of Commons mind would give the UK power
to terminate the Irish backstop and only
use permission I'm not sure the EU would
see it that way if this amendment passes
and there you have it we're going to
show you the numbers on the side of the
screen there the way these things work
is after the votes are counted as the
MPs pass through their lobbies as
they're called the tellers then assemble
in front of the mace in front of the
speaker's chair and the eyes and the
nose will report how many MPs voted
either way now the expectation John
Craig the expectation is is that this
one will not pass this is a fairly
hardline brexit ear amendment I mean the
names on it
John Barron Andrew Ross and L for
example Frank Field Labour brexit ear
his names on it as well Sir Edward Lee
as well sir Mike penning Nigel Evans
former Texas speaker he's a pretty
hardline brexit ear this is going to be
heavily
in Villa Blanca I mean does that was
saying there I mean if it did pass the
withdrawal agreements there's no way
that the EU can sorry that the UK can
terminate the backstop on its own
absolutely right if this passes it
negates the withdrawal agreement it's
then a different agreement not the one
negotiated by to resume so in effect it
negates the withdrawal agreement so that
means it's rejected if this amendment is
passed which I don't expect it will be
taking up a point which was made earlier
about what happens if and possibly when
Theresa May loses the vote it's made
difficult for her I think to follow
David Cameron's precedent when he was
defeated on the vote about armed
intervention in Syria because the
opposition all knew what they wanted
which was no armed intervention but here
the opposition are divided between in
compatibles
people who want a harder brexit and
people who want a softer brexit or no
breakfast at all so there's no way she
can say I bow to the will of the house
because there is no winner of the house
and o-positive we love the house so what
does she do and also something has to
happen that's the difference isn't it
there isn't a position where you can
just walk away we have to but I think
back to the moor isn't she that's the
point is not do I bow to the will of the
house the point is do I accept that my
version of the deal is dead and that is
the point that she and I suspect she's
going to be very unwilling to do that
but if the numbers of our high it may be
possible that she just feels so shamed
into it that she accepts that there
needs to be another path and that she
indicates that something else is going
to have to know that she's gonna have to
come forward with some really expect
that to happen I mean there could be
blown out of I wouldn't give up I will
yes this is Theresa may knowing Theresa
may I would bet against it but I think
that if you're getting up into the high
hundreds there will be people in number
ten saying really there is a point at
which you need some credibility here and
if you're losing by high hundreds how do
you expect ever to get because I was
just told to declare Perry the business
Minister and she was talking about other
attempts plural that she will go back
yes Oliver from from those negotiations
with with Angela Merkel that the hope
that perhaps something something more
there is
chok amongst mps today that that is
what's going to be Plan B Pam B is a bit
more of the same it's Plan A plus I
think it's really sounds hopelessly
twofer optimistic I thought it was very
interesting towards the end of her
speech to the Commons there the extent
to which she was appealing to listeners
at home people listening to expected
voters rather than to fellow MPs talking
about the role of politicians and
elected MPs actually fulfilling their
duty and their their role as servants of
the people if you like and perhaps this
feeds in some way to why the Tories are
still despite all this mayhem
significantly ahead in the polls seem
very John Craig I mean DC seem to think
it seems something hard to me you know
we we know that treason a takes that
public service element of the job so so
seriously and talking about the national
interest yes and her I'm told that her
speech to her conservative MPs last
night was quite emotional as well
talking about her long career in
politics even before she was a member of
parliament she was a member of Merton
Council and that MP said actually that
was one of our better speeches to what
we normally call the 1922 committee last
night some of the previous ones not been
so good yes we're looking if you look at
leave me an eye on that yeah the whips
the whips come up before the table on
the right hand side of our screen it
would all be the government whips and
one of their whips will announce the
results and we expecting a pretty big
victory for the government yes and the
chamber more or less it is full I mean I
people who are inside the chamber are
saying that it's the most full they've
ever seen it I mean the press gallery
will be back now just you've got some
interesting information about the
strangest gallery yeah I mean I was
looking at a few tweets Sally berkos in
the gallery she who of course had the
controversial sticker on her car last
time I looked it wasn't there I couldn't
see it
Sept Corbin jeremy corbyn's son Philip
may as you might expect Sadiq Khan's
there as well I want one tweeter said he
was giving labour and Pisa a bit of a
look the evil eye perhaps but just so
just to explain to people that the view
of the Commons we're looking at now is
from underneath the public gallery
and at the far end behind the speaker
above that clock you can just see that's
the press gallery and either side above
the labor back benches on the right of
our screen and the torii back bench is
on the left of our screen there are some
galleries at the side and they will be
full they're like overflow galleries and
they will be full of MPs probably a lot
of peers in there as a Pierce galleries
well on the right hand side looking at
the screen but it's see how many MPs are
standing there at that's called the bar
of the house and tris Tereza mayor said
in her summing up her there that this is
the most important event that they will
have in their lifetimes not this one
though this is an amendment to the
withdrawal agreement that's going to
come next endeavor she just explained to
those of you just joining this this is
an amendment giving the UK the power to
end the so-called Northern Irish back
stop has been so contentious throughout
the negotiations of this withdrawal
agreement so many people implacably
opposed to it particularly on the
conservative side and indeed amongst the
Democratic Unionist Party who are
keeping the Conservatives in government
I'm just keeping an eye on whether we're
going to get a result on this we are
expecting it not to pass we'd like to
see by how many as the the whips the
people who who count up the votes tell
and lining up there the tellers yeah
right in front of the speaker let's hear
[Music]
the eyes to the right were 24
the nose to the left were 600
[Music]
the eyes to the right 24 the nose to the
left 600 so the noes have it
the noes have it unlock thank you well
let's put the numbers up for you if we
can 600 against 24 a vast majority and
if a rare occasion there where you've
got the two big parties voting the same
way yeah we should say against against
there yeah and 24 I mean I said it was
it was the right-wingers if you like in
the hardline brexit ears and not many
more 576 majority well just listen what
the speakers really
[Applause]
Claire love me
so the moment of truth arrives a rather
damp squib as hors d'oeuvre there in
terms of that amendment thumping Lee
defeated this is the one that matters
this is voting on Teresa Mays brexit
deal two years in the negotiation it's
the best deal the only deal around the
prime minister said she ended this five
days of debate let's get a sense of the
occasion our editor-at-large adam bolton
is in Downing Street I was gonna say
it's all to play for Adam but it's all
about the numbers here really isn't it
yes it is I mean that majority of 576
defeating that amendment for a job Baron
I mean that may be a record already this
evening I'm not quite sure about that of
course I think that division took about
20 minutes and that's because obviously
600 people went through one division
Lobby so the actual queues to register
their votes would have been even longer
than usual and one MP has already
tweeted saying that John Baron was
coming in for quite a lot of abuse from
his colleagues for forcing them to go
through the division lobbies he did have
the opportunity not to put his emotion
to a full vote but he decided not to do
that but this is this is the big one now
and just from the shouting at the
beginning it was quite clear that those
saying yes in support of the
government's bill were not as loud or as
prolonged as those shouting no so I
think all the indications are that this
probably will be a slightly closer vote
so it should be a little bit quicker I
should take around about 15 minutes but
it does look as if the government is
heading towards the defeat and I think
that will raise one of the questions
tonight not what mrs. May is going to
say because we're pretty sure that she's
going to say she's going to bring back a
version of this after further
discussions with Brussels tonight
wyndi Morton and Ian Stewart tell us for
the nose Viki Foxcroft and Nick Smith
tell us for the eyes Wendy Morton and
the in Stuart are on the right of your
screen as they approach the Speaker's
chair if they are they will have one for
the governments and a lot of people are
not expecting that but you know as I was
saying really the key question now is
what the leader of the Opposition is
going to do is mr. Corbyn tonight going
to call for a vote of no confidence in
which case that would take place
tomorrow his tendency his preference has
been to speed things up where necessary
and of course Wednesday is already a
busy day for him because he has to
appear at Prime Minister's Questions or
will he wait until tomorrow so that I
think is probably the biggest question
along with the bigger one of just how
many MPs are going to oppose the
government in this key vote the
so-called meaningful vote won by Gino
Miller and colleagues in the Supreme
Court okay Adam thank you very much
indeed
well those green benches in the House of
Commons fairly empty right now because
the vast majority of MPs still voting
for or against Theresa Mays brexit day
let's go to the heart of Parliament now
our Deputy political editor Beth Rigby
is in a central lobby there and what an
atmosphere it must be as Theresa May was
saying in her speech summing up of these
five days of debate the most important
moment in any MPs there any of their
careers yeah she went on didn't she said
that it was a decision that will define
our country for decades to come look it
is electric down here I've got Matt
Hancock Matt Hancock do you want to come
on he doesn't want to talk yeah he might
talk to me after the vote the the health
secretary and I'd say my heart's
pounding it's it's
really busy down here because actually
in 15 minutes also we're going to find
out whether Theresa May will go down in
history as the prime minister who faced
or saw the biggest defeat in a century
in over a century there's only been
three occasions in the past hundred
years in which a crime Minister has
faced a defeat or seen a defeat of over
a hundred votes and they were all during
the 1920s Ramsay MacDonald's minority
labour government and just to put it
into context as to what we are expecting
our own analysis has suggested
potentially a defeat by over 200 votes
in a senior minister said to me earlier
today he's been very closely involved
with the debates and the discussions
that he thought 150 to 200 could be
where that lands and that will be pretty
sensation it will be an enormous moment
and as Adam was saying will then be
seeing whether or not Jeremy Corbyn
decides to lay that vote of
no-confidence on Teresa Mays government
whether he decides to table that tonight
whether we have that tomorrow the other
thing that's happening Darwin is that
people are maneuvering so I've just been
told to watch what the second referendum
Locke do I'm told that overnight a
number of Labour MPs are going to come
out and say Mays deal is dead we're now
pivoting to a second referendum I think
they're going to make that announcement
tomorrow morning and try and make some
fanfare of that because they're trying
to get momentum now and then the ERG is
what are they going to do well watch
what happens after that vote I'm told
that they're going to be coming out here
and coming on to our cameras to make the
case of May's deal is dead let's go for
a No Deal brexit and also the norway lot
those who want a softer version of
brexit I'm sure they've got some plans -
so everyone manoeuvring in expectation
that Theresa Mays deal will fall we'll
be seeing what she will do we should
come back tonight will she come back
tomorrow but be in no doubt this is
going to be
a huge parliamentary moment the most
significant in decades okay Beth thank
you very much indeed for they the inside
intelligence they're well before the
maneuvering starts we got to get the
results of this vote our political
editor Faisal Islam is here with me
still a way to go I would suspect given
the the number of empty green branches
are still there the voting still taking
place so Faisal Islam they're not beasts
first of all is there been some
expectation management going on they
were these sense of a huge vote against
Ariza may can she say it's she's done
better than expected if it's 150 well if
these were if these were figures being
spun by number 10 then that would be the
case but simply speaking we number but
number of them media organizations have
simply asked MPs and not just ask them
before Christmas when we originally
thought those were going to happen we've
asked them in the past week or so
so can only report what they have told
us it's possible that there'll be a
shift those people who say I'm not going
to support the government maybe they'll
abstain but I think the context here
this is this you know if it's triple
figures it's a historically terrible
number as Beth I'm saying if it's
anything like 200 it's kind of
completely unthinkable for a prime
minister on any type of legislation let
alone in the legislation 4 which is the
basic purpose of their government to
deliver it is an unthinkable number over
200 so let's just see it of course in
the blind secret voting of the
confidence votes it was fairly unclear
that I think we're ashore EMPs would not
tell us the truth but all of the voting
lists will be published and we'll know
who's voted which way the sorts of
traffic that we've seen over the past
couple of days it's been a tiny trickle
towards the May deal on the Tory side
but some the other way too okay
and some labor labor numbers will be
important and I think what we're getting
now is people already trying to play the
aftermath of this it is really important
that the Prime Minister has got to try
and own this moment in some way and give
Spencer let's move it on step-by-step so
she loses she loses big
she'll come back to make some kind of
statement mm ComStat and we're also
hearing it had already been intimated
that the European Commission President
jean-claude Juncker is staying in
Brussels that European Parliament is in
Strasbourg the moment he was due to an
event there but he's going to Brussels
he's gonna make some kind of statement
this evening she's gonna have another go
isn't she and she's gonna have another
go with European Union and do you think
she'll have another go with this vote I
think that's her plan I think if there
is some sort of meeting around an
emergency - the Brussels this is not
about happening and if that does happen
I do wonder I do expect Jeremy Corbyn to
table a no-confidence vote tonight I
think that is the plan and maybe just
maybe if she announces that there's
another leg of some sort of negotiation
does he put that off do they calculate
that they've got a better chance to be
honest that an opposition would choose
not to table a motion that no confidence
if she used to lose five hundred fifty
to two hundred would be an extraordinary
act in itself and I hit I think only
half-jokingly a cabinet source talking
to me today suggested well to be honest
maybe we just give the SNP some time to
get on with it and embarrass the
opposition into having a no confidence
vote given that it's going to happen at
some point anyway I heard from another
senior MP telling me that there's a mood
amongst conservatives this is somebody
appointed to a position by the prime
minister telling me that he felt that
there was a mood again that this would
be a resigning matter for the Prime
Minister if she failed again so it may
be that those are skeptical about the
Prime Minister's leadership are willing
to give her one more chance having done
that to Europe but you know there is
talk about her leadership as you'd
expect if the loss does reach reach
triple figures but I think our plan is
to plough on see what she can get out I
know that Europe held some stuff back
because they simply didn't expect it to
make it well they said didn't they they
said before this vote that it would be
banked and then that more would be
required yeah but whatever they've held
back probably well well there's two
different schools of thought that are
obviously diametrically opposite once
all of thought is if she loses by a
hundred fifty to two hundred she then
shows the Europeans that they've really
got to change their
their approach but I think there's
another more relevant school of thought
which is the EU may well think well
there is nothing plausible that we can
offer that can shift a hundred votes in
the House of Commons and I think one
point is is really important to note
here which is that yes the backstop is
the most offensive to those rebels a
part of this and the most cited but
actually there's a bunch of other
aspects to this Panthera mayoral deal no
not just remains i'ma break to decide
there's the there's the so-called
divorce bill there's the rule taking
aspect there's the ECJ having some sort
of continuing role in in the UK all of
these things have been cited as reason
so it isn't just even if you could
magically solve the backstop that issue
okay well if let's look at other way she
might go if she doesn't plow on where
this could she try something radical
could she say I am ruling out No Deal so
another thing I heard from the cabinet
source today was the notion that she
should see where the wind is blowing she
should see that that wind is blowing in
towards a more collegiate consensual
solution to this problem and don't let
it be forced upon you by shenanigans
from let wind bowls and the speaker so
we head off this canto my thanks revolt
onto the indicative vote students is
that that's from some cabinet ministers
wasn't discussed widely a cabinet this
morning so you know you would think that
a situation like this a potential triple
figure vote against your landmark deal
that you've put together over a year and
a half you would think that's a politia
a politician with guile would think
let's move quickly let's own this moment
let's shift gear in some direction you
know some of her allies are saying you
know ultimately you need to get tough
with one the problem is as a coalition
of problems as a coalition of the
uncompromising there is incoherent both
can't be right but she's shocked that
she can't go back to our cabinet can she
and sit them around the table and say
you know let's let's thrash this out
they're hopelessly divided as well
whichever way she goes she's gonna get
resignations so she's so jealous rage
out to labor and go a bit softer
Union you will get cabinet resignations
and potentially more conservatives
finding that too close relationship with
the EU too restrictive in future foreign
trade deals but the question tonight is
is it not just about tactics and
rhetoric is her fundamental strategy of
trying to find a majority in this
Parliament that is made up of
conservatives Plus D u P plus some labor
rebels is it fundamentally head you know
wrong is it fundamentally not going to
lead to the majority did the general
then apply this to the general election
of 2017 she hit the iceberg at that
point and we're just now getting to the
point where the captain realizes the
boat is sinking how we might be getting
the point where they the captain sites
the iceberg right in front oh don't
think we're to drag the Titanic yeah
reference out too much point where it
splits into and likely that goes to the
bar we're at the point where the man
playing in the deck chairs violins
rearranged yeah but you know let's say
let's explain to people what is
happening right now now they're the
chamber of the House of Commons filled
right back up the vast majority of MPs
have voted in this crucial vote on
Theresa Mayes brexit daily withdrawal
agreements that will lead to stories
mate says to an orderly exit from the
European Union or March the 29th this
year agreeing to pay the European Union
about 39 billion pounds going into a
transition period when the UK will stay
in total alignments with the European
Union while the future trade arrangement
is thrashed I just got the backstop just
a bit breaking I understand that that
tompas Glover's resigned as a PPS he
won't lay that soil that's a nice
gesture forgive me if I shaved a former
PPS he's a vice chair of the
Conservative Party I understand Tom pers
glove who was a part we've got the
result
the eyes to the right 202 the nose to
the left
432
[Applause]
the eyes to the right 200 there we
haven't see withdrawal and we defeated
by a majority of two hundred and thirty
two hundred and two voting for the prime
ministers with all agreement 432 MPs
saying no to tourism a Faisal Islam our
political editor and that's right at the
top land of expectations as a point for
their horrific results the house does
not support this deal but tonight's vote
tells us nothing about what it does
support nothing about how nothing about
how or even if it intends to honor the
decision the British people took in a
referendum Parliament decided to hold
and people particularly EU citizens
who've made their home here and UK
citizens living in the EU deserve
clarity on these questions as soon
[Music]
oh dear oh there's good people shouting
there will be an opportunity for other
points of order but the Prime Minister
must and will be heard the Prime
Minister those whose jobs rely on our
trade with the EU need that clarity so
with your permission mr. speaker I'd
like to set out briefly how the
government intends to proceed first we
need to confirm whether this government
still enjoys the confidence of the house
I believe that it does but given the
scale and importance of tonight's vote
it's right that others have the chance
to test that question if they wish to do
so I can therefore confirm that if the
Official Opposition table a confidence
motion this evening in the form required
by the fixed-term Parliament's act the
government will make time to debate that
motion tomorrow and if has happened
before Christmas the Official Opposition
declined to do so we will on this
occasion consider making time tomorrow
to debate any motion in the form
required from the other opposition
parties should they put one Accord
second second if the house confirms its
confidence in this government
I will then hold meetings with my
colleagues our confidence and supply
partner the DUP and senior
parliamentarians from across the house
to identify what would be required to
secure the backing of the house the
government will approach these meetings
in a constructive spirit
[Applause]
[Music]
but given given the new urgent need to
make progress we must focus on ideas are
genuinely negotiable and have sufficient
support in this house third if these
meetings yield such ideas the government
will then explore them with the European
Union Mr Speaker I want to end by
offering two reassurances the first is
to those who fear that the government's
strategy is to run down the clock to the
29th of March that is not our strategy
I've always believed that the best way
forward is to leave in an orderly way
with a good deal and have devoted much
of the last two years negotiating such a
deal as you confirmed mr. speaker the
amendment to the business motion tabled
last week by my right honourable and
learned friend
the member for Bekins field is not
legally binding but the government
respects the will of the house we will
therefore make a statement about the way
forward and table and amendable motion
by Monday
the secondary assurance is to the
British people who voted to leave the
European Union in the referendum two and
a half years ago I became Prime Minister
immediately after that referendum I
believe it's my duty to deliver on their
instruction and I intend to do so
every day that passes without this issue
being resolved means more uncertainty
more bitterness and more rancor the
government of heard has heard what the
house has said tonight but I asked
members on all sides of the house to
listen to the British people who want
this issue settled and to work with the
government to do just that
I will come to other colleagues but
first of all well the leader of the
Opposition Jeremy Corbyn Thank You mr.
speaker the results of tonight's vote is
the greatest defeat for a government
since the 1920s in this house this is a
catastrophic defeat for this government
after two years of failed negotiations
the House of Commons has delivered its
verdict on her brexit deal and that
verdict is absolutely decisive I hear
the words the Prime Minister but actions
of a government of the past two years
speak equally clearly she is only
attempting to reach out now to try to
keep her failed process and deal alive
after it's been so roundly rejected by
Parliament on behalf of the people of
this country labour has laid out our
priorities consistently No Deal
[Applause]
No Deal must be taken no deal must be
taken off the table a permanent customs
union must be secured and people's
rights and protections must be
guaranteed so they do not fall behind at
every turn the Prime Minister's closed
the door on dialogue
businesses begged her to negotiate a
comprehensive customs union trade union
leaders pressed her for the same thing
they were ignored in the last two years
she's only had one priority the
Conservative Party her governing
principle of delay and denial has
reached the end of the line she cannot
seriously believe that after two years
of failure she is capable of negotiating
a good deal for the people of this
country the most important issue facing
us is that the government has lost the
confidence of this house in this country
I therefore Mr Speaker inform you I have
now tabled a motion of no-confidence
and I'm pleased I'm pleased that motion
will be debated tomorrow so this house
can give its verdict on the sheer
incompetence of this government that
motion of no confidence in the
government just come to the lead I will
come to the right honorable done well of
course but a point of order the leader
of the house with permission Mr Speaker
I should like to make a short business
statement regarding the business for
tomorrow and the remainder of this week
I'm extraordinarily grateful to the
right honorable lady and I accept that
she can't be psychic as to what I'm
thinking I can't be psychic as to what
she's thinking
I think the smooth and orderly way to
proceed with this matter is to deal with
points of order first and then to come
to the right honorable lady's statement
which would be entirely proper and
doubtless helpful to the house and point
of order mr. Ian Blackford we should be
aware of the situation of what in the
clock is ticking we have got very little
time to resolve this the fact it has
taken us so long to get the service we a
leader of the Scottish National Party in
the House of Commons make some points
they in Blackfoot
what's a few minutes of drama five to
ten minutes ago the vote on the
meaningful votes approving the
withdrawal agreement set was as you can
see at the right of your screen
thumping Lee defeated by 432 votes of
202 a majority of 230 against the Prime
Minister the Prime Minister stood up and
said that she was going to countenance a
vote of confidence in the government's
and he also said of labour work on the
table it she listened to the SNP if they
wanted to do that but Jeremy Corbyn took
up the gauntlet instantly he stood up
slammed into the Prime Minister and has
tabled that motion of no-confidence the
government saying that it will be
debated and voted on tomorrow our
political editor faisal islam is here
with nice moving fast faisal yes and and
obviously we're going to get the vote
lists and it's pretty clear that there's
been some more resignations I mentioned
Tom personal vice chair conservative
party who resigned to vote against this
deal
matters a thumping defeat 230 majority
we were being quite cautious beforehand
it's exactly in line
with what we were told by MPs we
couldn't quite believe that the defeat
would be that big because it's worth
just putting it in context Ramsay
MacDonald 166 defeat he didn't even
write him 24 1924 didn't even run the
the biggest party in the Commons at that
point on an issue of such important I
mean by my calculations she must have
got hunt over a hundred Tory MPs voting
against this rebellion which is lots of
people voting against the Conservatives
for the first time in their life now the
stories of those individual rebels will
be fascinating too but I think what
you've seen now is the optics of a prime
minister that wants to try to project
that she's still in charge so she tried
to say well of course you know I mean
I'm gonna make some time for confidence
measure to get in there before Jeremy
Corbyn you've seen there the leader of
the Commons trying to sort of say yes
yes we're in charge here we're going to
set the timetable now for this
confidence vote okay you know this is
all about saying we are still in charge
having gone down to the worst defeats a
governing party has gone down too so so
she said I mean other interests in
history and like muna versal
suffragettes like that other thing she
said there in a brief statement was
running down the clock not our strategy
kind of ruling out well this is what we
thought was going to happen five weeks
ago so all that has been achieved by
that delay has been that the tight
timetable that could leave us with a No
Deal WTO brexit which the vast majority
of government ministers think would be
extremely difficult at the very least
and disastrous at the very worst has run
down by you know we've lobs across
already run down no we didn't achieve
anything and she said it didn't achieve
any extra votes there was frankly insane
in the contest in the context briefing
just before Christmas that she was going
to achieve changes and then achieve
changes that would lead her to win this
deal she's lost it by 239 it's also said
that she will give more on the so-called
plan B on Monday now presume she's going
to talk to the
Union I just got a tweet here from
Donald Tusk coming to the European
Council and this is what the old two
screws had to say if a deal is
impossible and no one wants No Deal then
who will finally have the courage to say
what the only positive solution is yes
and so that is the key and the Prime
Minister's opened her initial remarks
with that this is not a vote that has
given us a way forward it's just for the
minutes temporarily blocked our way
forward that's how she sees this I've
got a longer quote here from a
spokesperson from the European Council
and ends with this we will continue that
use process of ratification of the
agreement reached with the UK government
this agreement is and remains the best
and only way to ensure an orderly
withdrawal but the risk of a disorder
the exit has increased with this vote so
we're already getting responses from the
business community we're getting
responses from others saying that this
is bad news in terms of the risks of a
No Deal and shaul talk to our you can
almost a business plan as well what's
happened to sternum standing already
down a bit today
how does she win so the question now is
is there any plausible change that she
could win from the Europeans isn't to
turn that around to turn those numbers
around so she well let's do the math
you'd have to turn around 116 MPs would
have to change their minds what is it
what is the realm of possibility that
could change the mind of 116 MPs and I
can't see it instead it's about tactics
you know one of her cap and allies keyed
loyal allies saying she's quite a do
something drastic she's got a the only
way she does this in a way is to break
the coalition of the uncompromising
which is the hardline remainders and the
hardline brexit is maybe if you can kill
off once and for all one of those
options then the other lot come into
line do you do that you threaten the
brexit errs with a referendum on her
deal but then you split the Conservative
Party but then how do you get it through
Parliament otherwise that's even if you
have a general election how do you how
do it doesn't change does it change the
fundamental equation here today up India
it's a maze in a fog
let's get the thoughts of our editorial
rj allen but when he's in Downing Street
and let's just reflect her Adam first of
all on the on the scale of this defeat
for Teresa Mays withdrawal agreement
it's right in line in actual fact with
that with our with Sky News is some
projections isn't it and it's worst case
and I think we did see the tactics of
the government's opponents in making
sure that the vote was concentrated
directly on the withdrawal agreement and
the political declaration now I think
what was probably bad news for missus
may is that twice in the closing speech
she gave and then in the reaction she
gave having lost the vote she talked
about cooperation and looking for
solutions with other parties and other
MPs and both times there was giggles and
sniggering from MPs so that just shows
that her ability if you like the
goodwill towards people who do see her
as a potential honest broker certainly
isn't there at the moment and we also
know of course as her and Bogdan all was
saying earlier on that her cabinet its
divided as well as to which way to move
and in which direction concessions
should be made so she's got a third of
her party who have gone against them
more than the third of her MPs have
decided to rebel tonight with that
figure and over a hundred I heard Faisal
saying one hundred and sixteen I don't
know if that's absolutely confirmed yet
to be interesting to know but certainly
one MP and three now doesn't support not
just the prime minister but doesn't
support the government on brexit and
that's a very very difficult position to
be in
incidentally had she won tonight it
wouldn't necessarily be an all plain
sailing because the DUP told me on Sky
News that if she had won the withdrawal
agreement tonight they would have voted
against her in a confidence motion
because they don't accept their
withdrawal deal at
East tomorrow in the vote she must
assume that she's going to get the
support of the DUP okay Adam thank you
very much indeed just gonna go to Beth
Ruby in a moment or two in Parliament
central Lobby Pfizer's just our
political editor you just got some
numbers on the number of times eighteen
conservative rebels have it against the
prime axis voted against the prime
minister a coalition of the hard brexit
a--'s and the hard remainders and others
former ministers he's a terrible list of
names here eighteen almost exactly the
same number as voted against in the
confidence vote in the leadership jobs
how do you turn those we've also gotten
a quick note from jean-claude juncker
that's just worth saying I'm take note
with regret of the outcome of the vote
in the House of Commons is evening iota
UK to clarify its intentions as soon as
possible time is almost up our subjects
are okay fast moving let's go to Beth
Rigby in their central lobby in
Parliament's might want to hear from as
many MPs as possible under Beth Scott
some with her how did they vote Beth hi
darlin I have I have Lisa Nandi with me
MP for Wigan a Labour MP who voted
against reason may Lisa thanks for
joining us she lost by two hundred and
thirty votes can you believe that I can
believe it because we've had two and a
half years if the Prime Minister
refusing to reach out across Parliament
refusing to listen listen to large
sections of the public who hold
differing views from the hardliners in
her party on brexit and this is the
results even right up to the wire in the
chamber just a few minutes ago just
before she was about to face this
massive defeat she was still taking that
same belligerent tone not listening
refusing to countenance that there could
be any way but her way and that is
frankly why we've ended up here none of
us should be pleased about this
it's really really worrying stuff we've
got just a matter of weeks to go until
we leave the EU potentially with no deal
with no transition period with major
implications for manufacturing jobs in
constituencies like mine and whatever
happens tomorrow I'll be voting that I
have no confidence in this government
but whatever happens tomorrow this has
to mark the start of a complete change
of approach if not just from the
government but from Parliament as a
whole and just on that lease on the
change of approach I imagine what's
going to happen now is various different
factions in Parliament are now going to
really do the hard sell on their vision
of brexit given that 230 MPs defeated
may on us quite something I'm still
astonished by that result what do you
think should happen next well what we
can't have
is yet more of what we've heard for
two-and-a-half years it's been
grandstanding in French positions just
today in the chamber despite the death
threats against one of my colleagues the
harassment that we saw her outside
Parliament the murder of one of my
colleagues a few years ago we still got
and he's calling one under the traitor
and screaming betrayal in the chamber
we're all going to have to step out of
our comfort zones and start to listen
and to compromise and find a way forward
for this country it is possible to do
this in other countries that use
citizens assemblies to break the
deadlock it is possible for us to do it
but we can't keep dividing Parliament
and we cannot keep dividing the public
or we will get the same result over and
over again I mean ultimately Lisa you
are someone that wants to leave Shuker
you are not you are a second referendum
on team second Ref what do you think of
this without results in the implications
but it's not surprising because it was a
withdrawal agreement and a political
declaration that didn't really please
any community my community voted very
strongly to remain I think theses voted
to leave no one was happy with it and
Parliament as supposed to act as a check
and balance on the executive and it said
no so we've got to find a way through
this I suspect that it's going to be
very difficult for us to reach a
consensus on a way forward here
which is why it's important that we have
as a backstop referring this back to the
people now I understand you know there
are lots of colleagues who have
reservations about going to a people's
vote I don't think it's you know having
another referendum is not something
loads of people welcomed with relish but
if we want to stop ourselves from you
know falling off the cliff and leaving
without a deal we will need to get an
extension to the article 50 process and
the EU institutions are clear that
they're not just going to grant a small
time for negotiation but they will give
us more time for a democratic vote so it
is a way for us to avoid no deal but I
accept that you know we're going to have
to persuade colleagues here I was gonna
ask you that your peoples vote campaign
I'm told that overnight a number of
Labour MPs are going to come out for
your campaign now that heard they all
looks as dead as a dodo how many people
are you expecting to come over to your
team well I wouldn't want to put a
figure on it and you know why not well
because ultimately it's not for me to
announce what colleagues are going to do
it's a very this is a very individual
you know decision and you take into
account very strongly what your
community wants but I you know I smoking
to lots of colleagues privately who have
said that they can see particularly if
we're talking about avoiding though do
that this is a viable way forward okay
and just finally in terms of Jeremy
Corbyn and the no confidence vote which
is now tabled tomorrow the DP quite
clear to me actually earlier today Sami
Wilson on Sky News said that they would
vote with the government looks quite
hard given that for labour to win that
no confidence vote now the policy is to
look at all other options I know which
option you'd like him to pivot to least
what do you think Jeremy Corbyn should
do in terms of next moves well I think
that he should respect the decision that
he and
were made a couple of years ago and
accept the referendum result we had a
people's vote I campaigned heavily for
remain during that referendum and we
lost it I think that now we face a trade
off as a country between a series of
hard democratic choices and the need to
protect our democracy and a series of
hard economic choices and the need to
protect our economy and I think what we
should be doing in the Labor Party and
all mp's across the house should be
doing now is laying aside our entrenched
positions and trying to find a way
through that protects both as best as we
can I just ask you Lisa would you back a
con in Norway style option I know that's
what Lucy Powell one of your colleagues
and other Labour MPs are looking at is
that something you could live with or
would support I think we need a bespoke
deal for the UK I've always thought
where we would end up if we respected
the result of the referendum would be a
sort of EE A+ customs union model I
think there would be support in
Parliament for that and I think there
would be broad support in the country
as well one of the things that Stella
Creasy and I will be proposing on Monday
in the chamber is that the government
alongside this parliamentary process
also establishes a citizen's assembly so
that we take away this argument about
the will of the people which we've been
having for two and a half years and
allow the public to have some meaningful
engagement in instructing politicians
about what comes next
okay thank I'm sorry I'm going to have
to leave it there so Dermot what we do
have our MPs convinced that they don't
like Mays deal but you just saw that
there they're not really united on what
should Comdex back to you okay Beth many
many thanks for that it's just after 8
o'clock
you're watching Sky News a special
programme on dramatic events this
evening in the House of Commons where
the house have voted by a thumping
majority to defeat two resumes
withdrawal agreement from the European
Union let me give you the numbers and
they're right in line with the high end
of expectations 202 MPs voted for the
deal 403 voted a against it was a
majority of 230 against that deal 118
Tories voted against the government so
here 432 I should say voted against the
deal 202 for it John Craig our chief
political correspondent is here with me
and those numbers are just so stark for
the prime minister how could she
possibly turn that around we've got the
official breakdown now and they just in
shows the enormity of the task facing
her if and when she does bring this deal
back now the breakdown of the eyes 202
conservative was a hundred and
ninety-six Conservatives voting with the
Prime Minister
three Labour MPs we believe those who a
Frank field I think I'm right in saying
said during the debate he was going to
Kate Hoey and I think John man you're a
skeptics three independents not quite
sure who they are there's quite a few
independents in the Commons now for all
sorts of reasons the knows the 432 248
Labour MPs that's most Labour MPs all 35
scottish national party MPs five
independents voting with the knows a
hundred and eighteen conservatives as
you said the 10 DUP for plied come
Murray and eleven Liberal Democrats and
the one green fire okay John and John I
mean it's just been such a fast move
evening I mean that five minutes you got
that you've got the the result of vote
then the Prime Minister stood up said
she will accept her she will make time
tomorrow for a debates on a vote of
confidence in the government's she
didn't say he was going to move it then
we heard from the leader of the
Opposition he stood up said we're going
to we're gonna challenge you but clearly
I mean she was daring mr corbyn to do it
clearly she believes she'll win
tomorrow's votes and we've had
confirmation in the last few minutes
that the DUP there 10 MPs will vote with
the government so she should win
tomorrow barring a mutiny by some of her
own backbenchers just to confirm we saw
Andrea led some attempting to make a
bleeder enactment and then she did she's
what's going to happen it'll be Prime
Minister's Questions as usual then it'll
be the debate the vote tomorrow 7:00
p.m. same again he'll be back here at 7
o'clock tomorrow no doubt well
get reaction to those numbers got a nor
specious panel here I'm joined by the
former Downing Street director of
communications said Greg Oliver
political journalist and commentator
Isabel oak shots and constitutional
expert professor Vernon Bogdan or and
professor Bolton or first of all we've
very clearly found out what MPs are
against but what a pickle what are they
for
absolutely and perhaps Teresa mais best
tactic now is to flush out the opponents
of the deal as to what they want to have
a vote on whether they want a No Deal
brexit presumably Parliament will vote
against that to have a vote on a second
referendum because you me at the moment
there'd be a majority against that a
vote on Norway a vote on the customs
union a vote on whether they want a hard
border in northern arm in which
presumably they don't and then ask what
is the alternative to my deal idle
thought that would be her best tactic to
take command of the process well let's
say I get a sense we're gonna hold our
thoughts in the studio we want to get a
sense of what may be coming from the
heart of the cabinet no doubt plenty of
meetings emergency meetings taking place
amongst them want to join my colleague
Beth Rigby she's in Parliament's that
central lobby and has the health
secretary with her Beth hi Doug yes I do
I have Matt Hancock here the health
secretary who is doing the media round
after that rather astonishing defeat mr.
Hancock thank you for joining us on sty
news I'm pretty astonished that she's
lost by that amount
are you well it was pretty clear that
this debate wasn't going the
government's way and has been for some
time if you listen to the debate there
were an awful lot of opinions expressed
and clearly most of them against the
deal now I did I believe that the deal
is in the national interest and voted
for it with head and heart but clearly
we're going to have to discuss the way
forward with others in Parliament both
our own back benches are also in the
Labor Party and in the other parties and
with the DUP as well to find a way
forward that the Commons will support
amber rod has in cabinet and you'll know
because you'll there talked about this
idea of a cross-party consensus EU now
saying that the reason they has to give
up on her own back benches and look for
cross-party consensus to try and forge a
deal rather than leaving with no deal is
that where we're now at just to be clear
I'm not saying that because there's
there's backbenchers on the conservative
side who will have a very important
voice in the discussions over the next
few days to find out what the Commons
will support the thing is that we
discovered last week that there is no
majority in the Commons for no deal the
question is how we find a majority in
favor of a deal now no deal remains the
option that is where we get to through
the legislation through the law of the
land if there isn't a deal that is
supported if that makes sense and
therefore the task firstly is to win the
confidence vote tomorrow I strongly
believe that the Commons has confidence
in the Prime Minister and then the task
is to find a potentially negotiable set
of proposals that the the Commons will
support mr. Hancock
one in three conservative MPs voted
against their own prime minister voted
against their own government policy
isn't it just time for mrs. maid to pack
up and leave number Ted no certainly not
I think that would be a mistake she has
negotiated this deal but she's also the
best place to find and the deal that the
Commons will support that's
tasks that we have ahead of us so we had
thought that she would go back to
Brussels try and do more negotiation
around her version of brexit you now say
in that given the scale of that defeat
she should bend that idea give up on her
deal and try and find something new is
that is that we're where we are now as
the government or you are well I'm not
going to prejudge these discussions
cross party discussions discussions with
their own backbenchers importantly
discussions with the DUP I'm not going
to prejudge those by making a comment on
any particular way forward because we
need to listen the prime minister
clearly said that she now wants to
listen to the Commons so the many
disparate voices that were aired during
the debate actually a high quality of
debate in terms of the the way people
spoke and the different ideas that were
put forward and she's going to now have
that discussion with becomes the key is
that as we've made clear for so long No
Deal is not a good option a second
referendum would be profoundly divisive
the I I fully expect and hope that the
Commons will support the Prime Minister
in a confidence motion tomorrow and that
leaves the answer of finding a deal that
the Commons will support taking that to
the EU and negotiating on that what
could that deal look like are you now
pivoting to kind of Norway style version
of brexit I know that some something
your colleagues have been talking about
is that where you think it could land my
colleagues have talked about a lot of
different alternatives if I may say so
and the point about listening is I'm not
going to prejudge that the Prime
Minister is going to listen to senior
parliamentarians on all sides and try to
find a way that forward that can command
their support okay thank you very much
mr. Hancock
so there you have it David it looks like
to resume dashing back to Brussels to
keep this deal alive maybe fade in mr.
Hancock suggesting there that it now is
time to try and build a cross-party
consensus to get some version
exit through the House of Commons back
to you okay Beth many thanks about well
if she does and when she does so go back
to Brussels so we already know the
reaction part of the reactions he's
going to get via Twitter we've heard
from the President of the European
Council don't Tusker he said and this
was an immediate reaction to that vote
he said if a deal is impossible and no
one wants No Deal was the Prime Minister
more or less said then who will finally
have the courage to say what the only
positive solution is he didn't mention
what he thinks it is and then the
president's the European Commission
jean-claude Juncker said I take note
with regret of the outcome of the votes
in the House of Commons this evening I
urge the UK to clarify its intentions as
soon as possible time is almost up quite
ominous Lee well that was sir how MPs
voted in the House of Commons and of
course all of them said they were trying
to divine what the will of the people
was well let's see how people who have
been outside to being outside all day
and indeed for many weeks now outside
the House of Commons both levers and
remain as our correspondent David bode
is with them David yeah and I think both
sides happy but for entirely different
reasons neither of them but nearly like
the deal you've missed all the standoff
really it was all very good-natured but
there was lots of singing you can
probably see the police just marshalling
the probe rigs it tears who were quite
noisy earlier on saying we've got a
better flag than you and if we just pan
round to the left Martin you'll see that
the pro-eu mob the remainders are around
here they quite joyous as well I think
nobody was surprised by the result
everybody surprised as we've heard by
the sheer scale of the defeat but nobody
really satisfied I mean I was speaking
to a leave means leave Regional
Coordinator a few minutes ago when he
said look you know we just need to get
to the 29th of March now let's just get
out with WTO we'll do fine for us but of
course
the pro remain groups are saying now
look let's just have another referendum
let's put it to the people again let the
people decide because quite frankly
neither side believes that the people
across the road from where I am now
simply aren't doing their job
and have made a complete holics of this
so I think everybody both happy and sad
at the same time if that makes any sense
happy that this has being voted down sad
that no side appears to be making any
progress whatsoever but does everyone
keep saying the both can't be right okay
David thank you very much indeed David
Bowman that side dad he has a comment
said with some of the protesters and
that's our last point he made about a
second referendum so called people's
voter my colleague our deputy political
editor Beth Rigby is with someone a
former cabinet colleague of course of
treasom ace who supports that very
option Beth
yes diamond I'm here with Justin greed
in the former education secretary who is
now a people's voter who is a rare
convert on the conservative benches
Justin what do you make of this defeat
well I think it's right at the top end
of how bad it could be in a sense for
this deal I think the deal is absolutely
dead what we don't need now is anymore
procrastination how do we have this vote
before Christmas we had the same result
but we'd have had an extra month for
Parliament's now work with the
government on how to get through this
next chapter in Britain's history so we
now need no more procrastination we need
to find out whether there's a consensus
in this house for anything there are
only a limited number of options that
does not need to take weeks frankly you
can have those votes in days and we then
need to get on and work out if there is
gridlock in this place and there is no
consensus then it will have to go back
to people personally I don't want a
general election this is not about part
of politics that's been one of the
challenges for Parliament I think then
you have to go back for a referendum but
we need to test and see whether there's
a consensus here just before we go on to
next steps we just reflect for a minute
on the scale of that defeat I mean it's
one in three Conservative MPs voting
against Theresa May but as you were
saying to me if you put the government
payroll back in I mean barely any
backbenchers came out in support for her
I mean we're seriously does it leave her
as a prime minister be she is completely
defenestrated here isn't she well I
think the challenge is that there are
broadly three routes ahead for Britain
you can have a hard brexit that's what I
know many people who voted for
excellence and you can do what the Prime
Minister's do done and come up with a
soft Breck's option I happen to think
it's probably the best one she's come up
with or of course you can keep the
current deal but it was very very clear
in many communities around our
people just didn't think this
middle-of-the-road option work they
think you're in or you're out and that's
been really I've been part of it I know
but what I'm asking is did you really
think she can carry on as Prime Minister
when I mean one in three of her party of
voted against a duel she's been working
off for two and a half years well I
think she should have listened to people
earlier but the bottom line is I think
she has to do now listen to Parliament
and I think we've had a leadership vote
I supported her for Prime Minister I
don't think that solves anything right
now I don't think a general election
solves anything right now I'll be
certainly not supporting Labour's
no-confidence motion tomorrow the last
thing frankly Britain needs now is the
Jeremy Corbyn government what we do need
to do is roll resolve brexit which is
not about party politics and that's why
Parliament now needs the chance to test
the different options we can't find a
consensus we then have to go back to
people I'm afraid to say and allow them
to find a consensus for themselves you
you you're a backer now of the second
referendum option just a handful of
conservatives I know it's a much bigger
movement on the Labour benches are we
going to see more conservatives come out
overnight and in the coming days for
that option do you think I'm sure all
conservative MPs will have been
reflecting care feel what the right
route forward is my view is going back
to the people will be necessary there's
not going to be a consensus in here for
anything I don't believe I happen to
think it's the right thing to do this is
such a momentous choice for our country
it's right to give it back to people and
I think that conservative MPs who share
my view that the last thing we want is a
general election more upheaval and
risking a Jeremy Corbyn government I
think many of them will reflect if you
do have to go back to the public for a
choice then that should be a referendum
mr. Hancock was just on and he said that
what the Prime Minister was going to do
now who was talk to opposition parties
and MPs and see if she could find some
form of consensus does that sound
sensible to you
yes of course but we're on a time line
we are leaving the European Union on a
29th of March because of the delay we
now have limited time for those
discussions to happen they can be rapid
many MPs have already thought through
what their views are on other options we
now just simply need the chance to test
them as we were able to test the will of
the House for the Prime Minister's deal
tonight as it stands a hard deal voted
down the default option now is Noda
where career into node about 73 days to
go how worried are you now about a No
Deal option given that mrs. Mae has lost
so emphatically tonight well I think it
would be a concern if the house now
expressed its will in relation to No
Deal which I think would be equally
emphatic that MPs representing people up
and down the country do not want No Deal
I think would be deeply concerning if
the Prime Minister and the government
chose to press on regardless we now need
to see if we can find the consensus in
Parliament if that is there we will
follow that route if it's not there then
we have to go back to people and find
out what the path forward is that they
want for themselves right thank you very
much screening for Tory to me well there
you have it Dermot I mean
parliamentarians you can see are clearly
now determined to take over this process
and you heard miss green in there
talking about a desire for the Prime
Minister to rule out no deal she's not
alone there's a number in her cabinet
that want her to do the same anyway I'll
bring our come back with more MPs and I
get them back to you any more there okay
Beth many thanks for that and on that
issue of a second vote a second
referendum I just got a tweet here from
the SNP leader there First Minister
Nicola Sturgeon saying a historic defeat
for the prime minister's been obvious
for months that it was coming enough
time has been wasted time to stop
article 50 and put this issue back to
the electorate taursus and noting that
Scotland voted to remain and it should
not be dragged out against Scotland's
will well it's all now where more with
my panel
so Greg Oliver as former director of
communications in number ten what would
you advise Theresa May to be doing
tonight after
scale of that divide advisor to do
exactly what's happened and I think in
these circumstances you've got a look
for who are the cabinet ministers that
are going out representing number 10
what were the two key words that Matt
Hancock said over and over again
cross-party this is not a government
that is prepared to go back with this
deal I think it's accepted that the it's
deal isn't going to work but what they
do need to do is now loosen off and see
if there is a solution in the House of
Commons
amber Rudd has suggested that view Matt
Hancock coming out tonight saying it
saying after what the prime minister
said that the despatch-box is now clear
that that is their tactic okay but how
does she go about that she needs a forum
I mean could it be through that liaison
committee that will look Padilla's
interesting I think she'll probably
start by trying to talk to people like
hissed armor people like Hilary Benn who
are who is the brexit Select Committee
Chairman and just try and find a way of
how do how does an amendment get
suggested that is not necessarily from
the government that emerges from the
House of Commons and how do you keep
trying to find the phrases in the words
which will just push it over the top
because they are allergic to having a
second referendum both the Conservative
Party and the Labour leadership or at
allergic to that she's not going to push
for a general election and she'll win
the vote tomorrow it's a broad shot but
if it goes that way the brexit gets
softer and softer and softer we know
that's the mood in the House of Commons
so I think the only thing that there
would be a majority for at the moment is
some form of soft brexit Labour's made
their position very clear about the
importance of the customs union and the
single market so the agony for the
Conservative Party is even if they can
get some kind of deal through if the
government can get some kind of soft
brexit version through Europe goes on
dogging the party for the foreseeable
future
breaks it then does not go away I think
we could see the formation of a new
political party we would see the
Conservative Party deeply split let's
not forget that where the Tory members
stand on this most of them a decent
number of them are quite comfortable
with the idea of no deal and will be
utterly outraged at a soft brexit and
they will not forgive MPs who have
pushed that forward yeah interesting
beer your thoughts on that
a new party I mean that the sense that
the Prime Minister could sacrifice her
party for the good of the country well
it does raise the whole question of
party realignment because obviously the
Conservative Party's divided down the
middle on Europe Labor's divided down
the middle on Corbin's leadership indeed
the majority of Labour MPs as was shown
in 2016 were against Corbin's leadership
because by about a four to one majority
they passed no conference in him but he
carried on regardless so in a system in
which it was easy to form new parties if
for example we had proportional
representation we might well see break
aways from both parties but of course we
don't have that system we have
first-past-the-post and the penalties
for forming a new party are pretty heavy
as the SDP found out in the 1980s so
that may be unlikely in the immediate
future but I mean Isabelle Oakshott made
an important point I think that the sort
of the brexit the more hostile many
conservative MPs will be - Teresa May
and I'm doubtful whether than some magic
bullet that you can get from consulting
members of parliament as to what
solution would command a majority and
people talking about Varys magic bullets
Norway without perhaps having gone into
Norwegian situation very closely a
customs union second referendum all
these things are at least as divisive as
the deal which has just been rejected
crucially are they as divisive as no
deal and I think that if you speak to
people in the House of Commons the one
thing that they are totally allergic to
is the idea of crashing out of the EU
without a deal and they think that that
would be a major problem uncharted
territory as the prime minister said
herself want to go back to central lobby
and better EB is one of the key players
in all this the man who resigned when
the the origins of this agreement were
unveiled to the cabinet back in July at
Chequers speth yeah that's right hello
I'm here with mr. Johnson who as you
said resigned
from cabinet over checkers couldn't bat
checkers wanted it chucked it wasn't
chucked - now look where we are mr.
Johnson
one in three conservative MPs voting
against their prime minister a two
hundred and thirty vote defeat are you
astonished what's how would you describe
it what adjectives would you use look
it's bigger than I the margin of defeat
for the government is is bigger than I
it's no particularly cause for for
rejoicing for me because after all I've
been trying for so long to get the
government you know back in in the place
that the Prime Minister was that in her
Lancaster House speech in in January
last year when we were really talking
about taking advantage of brexit with
real free trade deals really taking back
control of our laws and then all that
got lost as we moved into this quick
sound of the Northern Irish backstop
locked into the customs union locked in
the Sigma market so what she has now in
my view is a massive mandate 432 votes
against her deal she takes it back to
Brussels and she says we can't do this
deal as it is need a fresh approach and
that's got to be keeping the good bits
you know looking after making sure we
protect the rights of the 3.2 million
European Union citizens here in the UK
very important keeping the stuff that's
been agreed about current cases before
the European sorry just to be clear with
73 days to go you think she should go
back and begin the negotiations again
and what extended article 52 do so no
you don't need to do that at all because
as I was as I was just saying there are
bits of than the of the withdrawal
agreement that are fine the stuff on
citizens are stuff on the court keep
keep them cooler carry case before the
court
take out excise surgically remove the
backstop okay that's the problem
that's the lobster ball that's the trap
that keeps us locked in the custom
Museum and and means we had this
terrible Hobson's choice between as it
were sacrificing Northern Ireland or
remaining subject to the EU without
having any say in the Eve's that's that
that's the trap that needs to come out
and what we need to do there is use the
implementation period which runs from
March 29th for a couple of years 18
months or more to do the free trade
agreement that is eminently doable when
you consider that the UK and the EU are
all already completely alive so just to
summarize what you think she should do
is go back to Brussels get the backstop
taken out of the withdraw an agreement
and and crack on with the deal and what
she should not do just to be clear what
she should not do not what I picking up
some rumours around this place what I
think would be absolutely fatal would be
to do any more kind of parliamentary
lottery and jiggery-pokery and coming up
with schemes to either to delay article
50 or to come up with a second let's
make this argument that hard deal or was
as of for exit areas you are hard deal
was the brexit ears chance to leave or
March the 29th with a deal and you have
emphatically voted her down now your
colleague you were minority in parlor
massive minority in Parliament your exit
is you want this sort of clean brexit if
you like you voted her down and
parliament are going to take control now
and and you've blown it haven't you well
except that you know defecated
parliament entrusted the people with
this decision about their destiny
Parliament said in 2015
folks do you want to be in the European
Union or not they said emphatically you
know by a margin of more than million
they wanted to leave
82% of MPs in this place then campaigned
on manifestos to come out of the custom
union come out of the single market we
have to deliver final point Beth I know
you gotta go but we also voted to
trigger article 50 which ineluctably in
actually means as we come on I do need
to go but I can't let you go without
asking you this she's lost by 230 votes
that said one in three conservatives
fate in her down because she
realistically carry on as Prime Minister
she's got absolutely no power left you
know we we in the Conservative Party we
went through all that in December last
year as you recall that's not the issue
isn't the honorable thing to step down
and this was not that the issue is not
the person what would you do personally
usually I would do what exactly what I
have I've just said and I hope very much
and that's what you're you you she still
has your fault back and she you think
she should carry openly vote for her and
for the Conservative government tomorrow
in the division lobbies because our one
thing I do not want is Jeremy Corbyn
taking over as our prime minister I'll
tell you that much for free ok thank you
very much mr. Johnson well there you
have it he thinks mr. Johnson thinks she
can go back and crack on and and do the
din again and I'm joined here now by
Sammy Wilson from the DUP mr. Wilson
thank you for joining us how are you
going to vote tomorrow in this
confidence vote in the Prime Minister's
government we will support the
government tomorrow I mean we have an
agreement with the government we want to
see them through the five-year term in
Parliament they lost their way and we
along with nearly half of our own party
voted against her tonight but we want to
get the government back on track where
it delivers on its manifesto where it
delivers on the commitments would submit
to us in the conference and supply
agreement and where it also delivers on
the promises that the Prime Minister
made since he was elected as prime
minister mr. Johnson that was suggesting
that she should go back to Brussels get
the backstop taken out of the withdrawal
agreement and crack on with her deal is
that what you think
well the backstop has been the problem
and all of this because a backstop those
two things first of all it splits up the
United Kingdom removes Northern Ireland
the rest in a kingdom and secondly it
was going to be used and that they Ino
Humira quite clear it was going to be
used as a kind of a barrel to push
Britain over when it came to the future
she a Shinzon the future relationship it
was that was to be the basis of the
future relationship something totally
unacceptable
so here's quite right remove the toxic
bit of the agreement and then let's move
on and establish a good relationship
with the EU which can be beneficial to
them and beneficial to us mr. all says
pretty unlikely I mean that the EU will
remove that the backstop I mean this has
been a key requirement of the Irish
government it's been something that the
eu-27 have support indeed the Prime
Minister I mean if she can't do anything
more on the backstop what should she do
well I mean first of all it has been a
requirement which is not necessary and
you know I've said time and time again
yeah I take that but what should she do
if she can't change anything on the
backstop she's tried her hardest he's
gone back and forth and back and forth
what next well she tried her hardest but
he you never believed that this would be
rejected and rejected in this way by
Parliament the you know faced with the
situation where the deal which they so
long for because is so good for them is
not going to be deliverable so they can
sit on their hands and wait until the
29th of March and then the problem is
solved because it's a way anyhow we've
we leave without any agreement so it
disappears they don't have the
embarrassment of having a step back they
simply have to accept that it's gone and
then they start negotiating or else if
they
to move much more quickly and bring some
more stability and confidence to their
own countries then they can start being
realistic from tomorrow and start
dealing with the Prime Minister in a way
which is much more even-handed than what
we have had so far okay thank you mr.
Wilson well there you have it in terms
of the confidence vote mr. Wilson
confirming again what he told me earlier
which is that the DEP will vote with
Theresa May in that confidence vote
tomorrow so as it stands tonight unless
a number have her own MPs who voted her
down tonight decide to completely
implode their government and go for an
election in which their jobs are up for
grabs - it looks like she'll survive
tomorrow as for her brexit do well
that's an entirely different question
yeah very very interesting indeed thank
you very much the exactly the same
Barrie be there in central lobby and I
want to reflect her with my panel on
there some of the comments that Beth got
there from Sally Wilson from the DUP and
of course the former foreign secretary
Boris Johnson and Isabella shot both
kind of making the the same point in
terms of everyone wants to know what
happens next and their recommendation
being you stick to the deadline March
the 29th but in between time and go back
to the EU they'll take the backstop out
of the way that all agreements in
everything we find there's some unicorns
in there I mean I thought that was an
astonishing intervention from Boris
Johnson he seems to me to have let's
hope very temporally taken leave of his
senses what he was proposing there was
that in the remaining time available
which I don't think is catastrophic Lee
shorter some people are suggesting but
nonetheless he was suggesting that she
has time to go back and ask the EU to do
something that they have persistently
refused to do all this time and he's
gone wildly off message as far as brexit
ears are concerned the message I might
have expected to hear from him tonight
would be to say this is obviously deadly
steel let's go for World Trade
Organization let us just crash out as
people are opposed to it would say but
the idea that he can't that she can go
back to Brussels and renegotiate it's
pie-in-the-sky okay only gray Oliver and
Sammy Wilson made the point that the
size of the defeat he thinks could
almost be and it
Vantage when going back to the European
Union there'll be they'll be so shocked
by the size we just reopened the
withdrawal agree we've just heard
magical thinking time and time again
from brexit ears throughout this process
you know people are going to be
desperate to flog us their Prosecco and
their German cars and we all we need is
plucky bits just to go up to go to
Europe and tell them what's Wars that
has been exposed over the last two and a
half years as a serious problem there
are 27 other nations who are more
interested in making sure that Island a
member is sorted out than somebody who
is leaving it is a fantastical solution
it is extraordinary this time that
anybody would say that but we've just
seen it
your reaction Vernon Boulder well
there's a great deal of misunderstanding
about the backstop I think no one wants
to see a customs border or regulations
imposed between Northern Ireland and the
Irish Republic
which would be ruinous for the economy
of both parts of the island of Ireland
and the question is how do you stop that
happening now one way would obviously be
to stay in the customs union that would
be one way of doing it and other ways to
find some technological development
which would obviate the need for that
which no one has yet discovered if you
can't do either those two things then
let us have something like the deal and
the deal does give Northern Ireland
access to the EU internal market without
needing to accept all the regulations of
the internal market do you think they
conceded too much on that and it keeps
the whole of the United Kingdom with the
tariffs and quotas free trade in the
customs unit without actually being
members of it and without the
obligations so the EU won't go any
further now if you reject the backstop
you have to find a way of avoiding a
border in Ireland which no one wants and
that despite what Sami Wilson says a
border in Ireland would actually
encourage in vain in Northern Ireland
because they would say we're now cut off
from our nationalists and Catholic
friends in the south
this is not what Good Friday agreements
about let's resume our campaign for
Irish unity so I think the backstop is
both a good deal for Britain but if it
seems tough and back to the start of the
negotiation and it's fair to say most of
the business community in Northern
Ireland and the farming community are in
favor of the deal despite the DUP
because they're terrified and customs
you mustn't holding Robert listen I'm
sorry to cut you off there we want to go
back again there's so much happening I
want to go back to the House of Commons
again they're more cabinet reaction from
the transport secretary is with bathroom
yes that's right David mr. gray Lynn is
with me mr. gray Leland thank you for
joining us on Sky News that was quite a
quick response from the Prime Minister
there was this game doubt in cabinet
this morning about what you would do
when she lost not specifically with
regards the tactics we had an extensive
discussion about what should happen next
having it very clearly behind the Prime
Minister recognizing that if the vote
wasn't won we would have to move fairly
rapidly to reassure I think the Prime
Minister did the right thing tonight
setting out first of all that she would
seek emotional confidence in the house
tomorrow that's clearly come it's really
important that she knows tomorrow that
Parliament still has confidence in her
and my government I think that's what
will happen
there's absolutely right where that
issue should be addressed straight away
she's then said there will be
discussions
first of all with conservative
colleagues secondly with our confidence
to supply partners in the dup but also
across the house to senior
parliamentarians what we have to do is
identify upon having said we don't we
won't take this approach what will
permit accept we've heard a lot today
about what people are opposed to it
really is time for everybody to come at
now with what they're in favor of okay
Liam can I just ask you some of your
cabinet colleagues and I'm thinking here
David Gore can Bharat on the different
side of the divide to you as a brexit
here they think that there should
potentially be some indicative votes and
free votes in the Commons to try and
find out where the majority sees do you
disagree with that as an idea well I
don't think we need to have indicative
votes what the prime minister said
tonight was that she would as a set out
on the motion of his past last week
she'll make a statement on Monday she'll
bring in amendable motion for the house
after that I think it's really time for
the Labour Party in particular say what
is it actually in a favour
is it trying to overturn brexit it
certainly looks like it is it trying to
extend article 50 certainly feels like
that might be the case and that there
are arguments about the customs union
keeping the customs union it effectively
means staying the single market and
keeping free movement just just finally
mr. gray laid a 230 vote just defeat
nothing we've seen certainly in the past
century when that number landed what
what did you think how did you feel were
you shocked what to be honest I wasn't
entirely surprised it's been pretty
clear for some time that the vote was
likely to be lost by a significant
margin I think now the questions of
parliamentarians in all sides okay so
what do you want it's no good being
constantly opposed to things you've
actually got to decide what you do want
and set it out and win the competition
Parliament for it that's what the Prime
Minister is now seeking to do okay thank
you Mr grayling so there you have it
mr. Grayle in saying that the Prime
Minister will now consult with
conservative colleagues followed by the
DEP followed by some other senior
parliamentarians to see if she can find
a way forward it feels pretty chaotic
tonight I have to say back to you
Sony does better thank you very much
indeed bethe Rigby there well we want to
get some my reaction from Europe now we
already heard via Twitter from the
European Council the European Commission
both moreless saying how disappointed
they are on pointing out that the clock
is ticking well Murray McGuinness is
first vice-president of the European
Parliament she joins me now from
Strasbourg very good evening to you miss
McGuinness Telesis and your reaction to
this vote well it's certainly a
significant vote it's a very significant
evening I think that there is clarity on
one issue that the House of Commons does
not like this deal but I would be very
cautious and I was listening to some of
the commentary before you came to me
about the entire focus being on the
Irish backstop because we need to
analyze why people in the House of
Commons voted a particular way remember
because they want to remain in the
European Union and wanted to make their
intentions clear in the hope perhaps of
a second referendum others voted because
they want a hard brexit some of course
have concerns around the backstop but I
was concerned when I heard
the commentary would suggested that that
is the only issue and I think what is
clear is that there is no support for
this deal in the House of Commons there
is no support for a No Deal but what is
there support for and until we know that
I'm afraid that there is still
uncertainty around the mindset within
the United Kingdom is there any prospect
of reopening that withdrawal agreement I
don't know you said you were listening
in we had an interview with the former
foreign secretary Boris Johnson a little
bit earlier and indeed Sami Wilson
brexit spokesman for the for the
Democratic Unionist Party both
suggesting that something could be done
between now and the end of March about
the backstop that perhaps it could be
taken out well perhaps I need to repeat
what I said I think the focus entirely
on the backstop is completely misplaced
of course it is an issue but the idea
that you could come back to Europe and
say guess what that we want rid of that
that one-third of the withdrawal
agreement would be dropped by the
European Union which doesn't just
involve Ireland and clearly I'm from
Ireland myself but also is a European
Union issue around how we deal with the
sensitivities of history and geography
on the island of Ireland and I think
that the British prime minister herself
is very sensitive to that issue as many
in the House of Commons are so I think
that the idea of simply taking this
result as a reopening or a demand to
reopen the withdrawal agreement is not
how I read it now we will have to listen
carefully because tomorrow there is
further debate around a confidence
motion for the British prime minister
which I think she's expected to win and
therefore she will have to if you're
like come forward and chart the next
stage of this process and I've said it
previously which may sound strange that
at least today we have certainty around
the uncertainty that's a first step and
I'm afraid we now have to work very hard
as politicians both European and United
Kingdom to make sure that we deliver for
citizens and that we can reach an
agreement by the bricks it days of the
end of March ah okay you think that can
still happen because that was my next
question you talked about there the
mists of uncertainty I mean can they
clear in time for the scheduled X
the European was the UK from the
European Union some colleagues in the
house here believed that even if the
deal had been accepted today that it
might be difficult to get all of the
legalities sorted by the end of March so
I think you are right to ask the
question can with this uncertainty that
deadlines be actually met at this point
and I think that's not clear but again
the United Kingdom are going to have to
look at that possibility there is a
speculation even before the vote that an
extension of article 50 might be
required but then for how long and for
what purpose but I still come back to
our core mission as politicians is not
to fail citizens I live and represent a
border region on the island of Ireland
the people I represent want a good deal
between Europe and the United Kingdom
and we want the principle of the
backstop honored as that insurance
policy but we wanted never to be used so
I think if we think about those we
represent as I hope colleagues in the
House of Commons will think about then
perhaps wiser cancer can prevail and the
British prime minister who I believe has
shown quite extraordinary resilience
even in her reaction today to that
enormous defeat I believe that she will
have to carry this burden further and
work harder to deliver a deal that will
work for both the United Kingdom and the
European Union
okay first vice-president thank you very
much indeed Mairead McGinnis there of
the European Parliament joining me from
Strasbourg we're going straight back to
there the House of Commons and that
confusion and uncertainty that sir
Mairead McGinnis sir described and we've
all seen this evening it seems it's up
to the MPs themselves to decide the way
forward under my colleague Beth Rigby
our deputy political editor has got 24
different parties to ask them what they
want
hi Dermot yeah I'm joined now by Tobias
l-word a defense minister and and
Hillary been the chair of the Select
Committee that pulled that amendment
this morning in order to see that
meaningful vote go through in all its
glory or disaster for the prime-minister
dependent on your opinion I'm going to
come to you fast mr. Elwood you said
this weekend that you would resign as a
minister if the Prime Minister did not
rule out No Deal
hasn't done it yet well where are we she
made very clear the concerns that I
think is right across the house that a
No Deal would not be good for Britain
will be very damaging economically and
so forth however there is a default
position that if we do not strike a deal
we end up in that position and that's
what we need to be careful of what
happened today a huge defeat but we
protested or the will of Parliament on
the deal that has been worked on for all
two years that gained agreement by 27
nations but parliament has voted down
she's now made very clear to see is
there a consensus across the house can
we do our duty as we're expected by the
nation to see whether there is something
that links us all together the reason
why this was voted down not because
there's another idea looming there that
everybody wants to jump on we didn't
hear anything from the leader of the
opposition to say this is my idea all
they want to do is have a general
election and be opportunists what the
Prime Minister will now do if I can
finish is to see whether all the
caucuses across the group actually have
something in the middle that we can
actually rally around you obviously had
members about no deal and and ruled out
Maysville were you encouraged when she
talked about trying to build consensus
across the house can you see a way
forward well I welcome the fact because
I express the hope that she would do so
that she said she will reach out but the
really big question is she should have
done this two and a half years ago and
secondly will she listen to what she
hears so for example people may say to
her you know what we're gonna have to
stay in a customs union to achieve the
objectives you set for two years she
said no no no we're not going to stay in
a custody I was however encouraged by
one thing and it's the point that Tobias
raised she said the government will not
run down the clock now the consequence
of that is she should now immediately
say under no circumstances will the
government allow us to leave with no
deal because biz